Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
Just checking in on you.
What's, uh, what's going on?
I am actually doing this podcast.
I'm in the middle of a radio tour right
now and I have a 15 minute break and I'm
on my way to the fucking airport after
that. And after bike Cleo, we, oh,
we're going to buy her some dog food, you
know, so my wife has some of the Fiji,
isn't it? Right? Boring. All right,
get out of here. Go lay down cutie. Um,
so I got a full day,
so I'm trying to knock out 15 minutes
before I go back to doing the radio tour,
which is why I sound like I'm already
off and running as opposed to my, you,
I guess I'm never chilled a laid back.
So I've been doing morning radio, um,
to hype my St Louis and Kansas
City, uh, dates that are coming up.
And, uh, then also I got this,
uh, Canadian tour that I'm doing.
And, um, so I just spent on the fucking
radio all day and everybody's just,
you know,
I was thought more Canadian fucking Djs
were going to bust my balls about the
Bruins. I guess you can't, you know,
considering not one Canadian team
is gonna make the fucking playoffs,
which is playoffs, which is insane. Not
One of them. Clio. Can you believe it?
Not The fucking blue blockade.
Douche is not Ottawa,
Not Toronto. Toronto, Toronto.
Not The fucking, uh, the Calgary
flames. The Edmond didn't.
Oil is the Vancouver Canucks
or the Winnipeg jets.
You know, I don't think that's
good for hockey. I mean,
it's a funny thing to bring
up as an American when I
go up there and believe me,
it will be brought up. Now I'm not going
to rub your faces in it. How could I?
Yeah,
but God Damn Bruins, you know,
we're a three seat now. We're,
we're like, we've launched
six of the last seven
fucking unbelievable. Thank God
for Toronto. Got To love Toronto.
Most generous fucking team out there.
They're always there to pick
you up off the mat, aren't they?
That's the only team we beat
fucking laws to everybody,
Rangers, Panthers, San
Jose, Anaheim, the kings.
And then we just fucking lost two to
one hat breaker to the fucking devils.
Now like we're playing bad. I still
think we're going to get in there.
You know what I mean?
I just want us to make the
playoffs so fucking clickbait. Uh,
Dan Shaughnessy doesn't start writing
his dumb ass fucking articles about how
they need to do something.
It's Selfie beat.
A coach is so fucked up cause you
got to deal with the Dan, Shauna,
C's of the world. How unathletic does
that guy look? You know what I mean?
He doesn't even look like he plays
chess either. He just looks like a dope,
let's say, and I don't, but
I've never just seen a deck.
Fucking guy should be run out of
Boston. His whole fucking thing.
He lives for the moment when
the home team isn't doing well.
That's his whole fucking thing. I had
never forget that when the fucking,
I think it was when the red sox won
the world series. Finally, he was like,
I don't even know how to
write this article because
she had doubt your negative
comment.
I bet if a fucking plane crashed into
the stadium and killed the whole fucking
home team, you that, that,
that article would be a breeze
as you pretended to be sad.
Um, oh dog. That guy drives
me nuts. It drives me nuts.
He should be writing for
a New York newspaper.
He Shits on fucking Boston
team so much. Um, so anyways,
anyways, where the fuck am
I cleo for the love of God.
Are you allergic to your bed?
That's all you do. Is itch now.
Huh? Look at that. Face that face.
That's stupid that my dog had
such a classic pooch face.
It's ridiculous. Is that
what they call you? Clean up?
Was that your nickname in
high school? Oh, poach face.
Can you get over there and lay down and
stop looking at me like I didn't take
you out. Well, I didn't take it
out. I let you down the stairs,
but I also fed you. Hey, get
over there. Lay down. Go on.
Fucking think doesn't even
listen to me anymore. Go on.
I shouldn't be yelling at my
dog. My dogs is senior now.
She's eight and a half years old,
so she's officially a senior.
So when I go and buy dog
food, I gotta buy, you know,
I got it by the advanced age
shit. You know the same stuff.
They're feed in your fucking Nana and
your granddad or whatever the fuck you
know, putting them in a
fucking home. That's the worst.
That's the fucking worst man.
At least according to every fucking
movie or news report you see,
it's just like, this is
a wonderful facility.
They're going to be listening to Mitch
Miller the entire time they are here.
All of our facilities are
top notch. They're going to
be getting wonderful food.
They are in great care. You can
visit them whenever you want. Right?
And then the fucking second,
you drive away. You know,
we fucking put a hard hat on your
grandmother and make her start doing some
fucking yardwork. Isn't that how it works?
I'm trying to steal her pension or is
this just all some Hollywood drama shit?
I Dunno. Like I said,
so I'm gonna have to tap out here
and then come back and about, um,
what a fuck is it in like nine minutes.
I want to go back out to the
fucking world of morning radio.
I literally had one of these
guys this morning, Cleo,
get over there and lay down. You
know, it's worried about this dog.
That thing won't shit unless I take
it down the street, which is great.
Is that what it is? You gotta take a shit?
Is that why you stare at me?
Is that what you're trying to
communicate right now? Huh?
Like someone who's still sound of mine
but has lost the ability to speak.
This is like a Metallica video. Cleo.
Gee, stop fucking looking at me like that.
I'm going to take you down the street.
All right buddy. I'm going to do it.
Fucking thing is staring
all through my head.
I just left you outside fucking
10 minutes. Why won't you go?
All right. This is going to
kill me. Okay. All right.
Well I'm going to be talking
to guys. We're not born there.
My dog's taken a shit
evidently. Um, so anyways,
[inaudible] these morning
fucking radio guys are hilarious.
They literally sit there and they go
like, uh, they'll just be talking to you.
A couple of them would like the
classic guys like just to clean up,
get over there and laid out going.
Get over there. Get over there.
Alright.
I wish dogs understood. Just
give me five minutes. Clio,
get the fuck over there. Lay down.
Okay.
I actually know what I think it is.
I think she wants to get up on the
couch with me. This is fucking loose.
I have a pit bull in the, any sound
of wind. Wind freaks her the fuck out.
A Sasquatch could literally come into
my house and she'd be like, all right,
let's fucking do this. Okay.
But if she hears a noise and she
can't see where it's coming from,
she just freaked the fuck out
right now I have the heat on.
I think that's bugging her and then
all of a sudden she becomes like this.
She turns into like a Chihuahua. You know,
those dogs always look like they feed
in for something. Like, come on man.
Just give me another hit, man.
She starts getting that look.
She starts like she's not
shaking yet. Thank God. Um,
but anyways, a couple of these
morning djs with a classic,
like they just taught like to call you
up, be like, hey bill, how you doing? Uh,
So-and-so from K, whatever. Believable,
blah, blah. Yeah. So listen,
we're going to be talking
here in about, uh,
about a minute coming out of this
commercial. Is there anything,
any subjects you want me to
hit on? Uh, and thing, uh,
you want me to steer you towards I,
you know, whatever I'm talking about.
I love, love La and he
is that guy. All right.
We'll be on a right at the end of this
break and then all of a sudden it just
goes,
wow. Yeah.
Alec Bode Bell Scalar that have
it. Also, you just like, dude,
what happened to the guy I
was just fucking talking to
drab to add his age. 18.
We have a rough to add.
We got some laps coming your way.
Okay.
Cut. Went to the local Yuck, Yuck. Fuck,
fuck bond. We got bill, but have a lab.
Well, what's been on your mad?
Um, I almost said it to
the guy, be like, dude,
what happened to the guy I was just
talking to five minutes ago? Um,
other than that, the rest
of them have been fine.
I have no fucking idea what I'm doing
here. But anyways, I'm getting ready to,
I'm ready to, um, to do this tour here,
going through Canada. And uh, you know,
I had those pick shows last week,
so I feel like I might have
been doing spots around town.
I'm fucking ready to go. I'm going
to be doing the treadmill by the way.
My Home Gym, the gym that
I'm going to have at home,
they're a [inaudible] doing the floor.
It's a three day process
cause I got the fucking the,
what's it called? It's, I got the, it's
called the lava finish. Assam Shit.
I know. Stupid fucking name, but
it looks sick, man. It's fucking,
it's got to look shiny and clean,
exciting and new. Lift some weights
and become a shredded freckled con.
He's Bill Burke.
He's tired of looking like
a sack of mashed potatoes.
He's going to do some tips.
Walked down the street shirtless
and get sun poisoning. Um, yes.
Everything's coming. So today, all the
gym shit is dropping off today. Right.
Which was so fucking funny.
Cause today I'm going to leave.
So it's coming ups and they're
just like a, you know, basically,
you know we're going to be there
sometime between 3:00 AM and 12 midnight.
Could you just try to be home in? Of
course I'm not going to be here now.
I got to tell the lovely Nia
and I was just like a sweetie,
what did you have planned
tomorrow? She's like,
well I was going to go to the
show. I was like, cancel it.
She got so fucking mad at me.
[inaudible] all this stuff to do.
It's like it's one fucking day to have
a free gym for the rest of your life.
Okay. You're going to get to go
out there. You're going to listen.
You're going to get to listen to your
music as opposed to the gyms. Music.
Now I know that you can put headphones on,
but every has those ear buds and the
fucking jamming in your ears and you're
basically blowing out your ear drums,
giving yourself tinnitus or tetanus.
However the fuck you say it. Um,
cause you don't want to listen to, uh,
what's that song? They always play
a, we are soul to soul, right?
It takes two to make a thing go wrong.
You know,
they play that for some reason Jim
music stopped in the early nineties.
That girl is poison. They
don't even play shit like that.
Did they stay place?
I don't want to fall in love,
you know, like songs like he goes, is
that Banana Rama, Huda Gouda. Fuck,
I remember this song,
you start thinking of the chick
you were dating at the time.
You start thinking about all
the fucking, all the time. Oh,
who's getting who the chick you wanted
to date but didn't have the balls to,
so you hooked up with that fucking monster
who is working in customer service,
right. To be a little
more accurate here. Um,
yeah, I, I don't like, uh, I'm not into
that shit. So anyways, so she has to,
she the poor things gotta be home all
day today. You know, with any luck,
it's actually between, like they said,
between 10 30 or 10 and five or some shit.
So hopefully I'm really
hoping that it's gonna. Um,
it's gonna come early, you
know what I mean? For the, uh,
the amount of pouting that
she did about, you know,
you know what's so funny too,
is whenever somebody says they can't
do something and they go, why, why,
what are you doing? And then they tell
you what to do and it's like, yeah,
you're not doing shit. You know,
cause you're so focused on what
you want them to do for you.
It's just like, yeah, you know, I, I lost
my passport and somebody found his ID.
He didn't do that tomorrow.
Yeah. I have a dialysis.
I don't know if I told you I have,
you know, double kidney failure,
so I have to do it. If I
don't do this, I'm gonna die.
You can't put it off the
fucking eight hours for me.
Wait, come on.
It's kind of going into
that mode. Um, but anyways,
Jesus Christ, who the fuck?
I don't even want to look.
Who the fuck am I Bruins playing next?
It's funny when the Bruins are winning,
you know, kind of paying attention.
But whenever they were in trouble,
that's when I fucking sit down and
watch because I'm a real fan. I'm the,
I'm there during the bad times.
That's half the reason why I
watch so many games this year.
I was just there going like, well,
they got rid of the whole fucking team.
You know, this is going to be a tough
year. So, all right, I'm going to see a,
I don't know. I'm a fucking nerd.
Like I watch, I like watching the,
the rebuilding of a team
so you can be there.
I remember when they brought that
guy up, dude, I fucking called it.
How about the fucking filthy
flyers? They all the capitals.
Hey, capital fans,
you guys finally gonna fucking push
through a you east coast San Jose Sharks.
You ever gonna make the fucking finals?
Can you do that for your God damn fans?
Huh? Um, all right, let's look
up the Bruins here. Scores, news,
video stats, standing schedules, players.
Fuck are the teams teams. There we go.
Oh by the way, I've been
going onto that French site.
I've been figuring shit out.
Um, I'm sticking with the dude.
I'm like 33 33 days in here. Alright,
watch episode 12 during
an off day in California.
Well the hell is this guy frank
for Trento and the Bruins.
Rookies explore La. Oh,
rough stretch of the ice improves
with a win over the leafs.
Why?
I don't understand watching these fucking
soap operas about your Goddamn teams,
you know, behind enemy lines or whatever
the fuck they were always doing.
What do they do that in the NFL?
Okay.
You know, jockish what is somethings
like unnecessary roughness,
what do they call it?
What does that thing,
that fucking thing they do on
HBO where Rex Ryan's like, Hey,
we'll beat any fucking team
and it's fucking league.
You know that he gets fired a fuck.
Our next game is tomorrow
night it gets to St Louis Blues
and then on Monday we play
the fucking Blackhawks.
Both of those are away games.
Then we have the hurricanes,
then we have the Redwings
and then we have Ottawa.
Fuck yeah,
this is fucking unbelievable. Are We?
Are we going to blow this? Oh wait,
what the fuck was that story
about what we got there?
What we go here. This is some rookie.
Why can't you fast forward
your way through the Goddamn,
I don't want to watch episode 12 of
rookie sitting on a fucking beach in La
talking about hockey. I don't give a shit.
I thought they was showing me some new
prospect that Bruins have. God knows,
but bring them up. We could use
them. Ninth annual cuts for a cause.
Everybody gets say head shaved
and hopefully at least you know,
half of one half of 1% will actually
go to the fucking cause through what?
I'm so down on every goddamn
charity now. That'd be fun. I mean,
I have to be honest with you. I've done
charities my entire fucking career,
but I have never seen just the
sheer number of charity. Oh,
there it is. Hey, all right. Going
to call you back. Talk to you.
In a minute. All right. I'm back.
Just knocked out another
two and I am done.
Probably talk politics
too much on that last one.
Everybody wants to talk politics.
I got Sally and Bella. Yeah.
That with all this stuff,
let's go out and politics.
There's gonna be a great solidly
Uncle Bait. It's like, yeah, no,
it really isn't. And
this one for some reason
is depressed the shit out of me.
You know what I mean? Jesus Christ,
eh? It's just, you know,
I'll tell you right now,
you can take that Donald Trump. You
can want him up in a ball. Okay?
You sticking right up.
You know who's who? Huh?
You roll her down the street into
the fucking garbage bin. All right?
And then you fucking, then you
gotta take Bernie Sanders, right?
And you've got to give
him that gun that fucking
Scarface had at the end
of the fucking movie.
And then you just gotta
send him in. You know,
you got to send them into one of those
banker fucking meetings and he just comes
it when, if know when they're doing the,
the annual international
bankers slash family picnic,
right? So you've got everybody
there, you've got the evil cuts,
and then you have the spawn of the evil
cuts and you just got to go in there.
I mean, even then, right?
What are you going to do?
Let's just say we buy into the fairytale
that everybody who's super fucking rich
is fucking evil. And then regular
people were fucking good people.
What will, you know? Then we'll
have their level of power,
then we move up and then we become
them, right? And then, you know,
you know it's going to happen. You're
going to be here, you're gonna have power.
You're gonna have influence
here. Come though, right?
Did it come the whores? It comes to
temptation. There's the pile of gold.
You're supposed to be watching
for everybody else. You know,
you could do the right thing or
you could go out and get yourself.
You fucking Bentley, you Lamborghini,
you could stay with your wife or you
could start banging at 22 year old
Victoria's secret model.
You know, decisions. Yeah.
Becomes tough. You know, and it did this,
it's like an earthquake when
the earth splits, right?
And your morals are on one side and all
the whores in the gold are on the other
and it's very hard. You know,
you gotta jump over early,
jump over early or it get you, you go,
you go too far down and then
it's just, what can you tell?
You're just caught up in it if
fucking caught up in it, you know?
And that's when I actually feel lucky to
be a balding red headed fuck because it
really keeps me in check. So sad. Um,
anyway, so let me do a
little fucking read here. Um,
what's the last time there was
a balding headed fuck you know,
of any influence, you know,
I think it's high time.
Balding redheaded. Fuck. Got a chance
to drive the bus, Huh? All right,
here we go. Oh, our old
friends, he is zip recruiter.
Everybody. Are you hiring?
Are Ya? Ah, God bless you.
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
You Wow. Posting your jobs
in one place. You know what?
Evidently, that isn't enough to find
quality candidates. Not these days.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on
all the top job sites. Well,
how to fucking you do
that? Well now you can't.
All right with zip recruiter.com you
can post your job to 100 plus job sites
including social media networks
like the Facebook and the Twitter,
all with a single click. That's how you
know you're old. When you say the right,
the Twitter, the Facebook, the Instagram,
these children are out of
control. Taking the Mali,
find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll in to Zip,
but great, easy to use interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your
office quickly scan candidates,
rate them and hire the right person
fast. I don't like that person.
They're fat and ugly. You
keep that under wraps.
You're not supposed to say
that. You supposed to say, hey,
that person with the dead tooth,
you know that I don't want to
look at every day. You know,
at the end of the day, they are the
best quality, quality candidate, right?
All who want to look at and say, I
all the want to fucking hire the
hot chick with detainees. Alright,
boss. She's a jolly good fellow.
Find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by over 800,000 businesses and
right now my listeners can try zip,
but up by for free, go
to ziprecruiter.com/byrd.
That's ziprecruiter.com/bar
ziprecruiter.com/berg. All
right, that's it for the reeds.
That's it for the reeds. Cleo, can you
get over there and lay down please buddy,
can you get over there? Just get over
there and lay down. Stop staring at me.
Go on, get over there
later. Go on. Go on. Go on
a for God sakes. Yeah. Step on my
laptop with the acute web toes.
Clio. Get over there. Go on.
Oh, you're testing me today.
Go on. It's a fucking
bed. It's comfortable.
You know,
he used to be a wolf and you had to
sleep outside trying to find a spot that
didn't have acorns underneath
you tell you this dog,
its fucking thing has no respect. Um,
I thought it had to go to the
bathroom. It doesn't cause I actually,
during that, uh, radio interview,
I went outside and she took a big dump
in my backyard that I now have to go pick
up with a plastic bag. Cause that's,
that's what a man does in 20 fucking 16.
Right. So now I realized that she
just wants to come up on the couch.
She's always scared. Right. You know what?
I know there's so many fucking dog lovers
out there right now then. You know,
nothing would make you feel better
than if I fucking brought her up here.
All right, come on CLIA. Come
here. Come on buddy. Come on.
Dog trainer would be pissed right
now. You gave into her. All right.
There you go. See that? Look at you snug
like a bug in the rug. Now you're fine,
right? All right, good kid. Um,
anyways, yeah, Jesus Christ. That's
all people want to talk about.
They just want to fucking talk
about politics. And I go, Hey,
I don't want to talk politics.
I'm not paying attention.
I don't know what I'm talking about. I
don't like, I don't like any of them.
And then everybody just, I, yeah. You
know? Yeah, but don't you take it,
you think it's all really just
talking about Trump and being like,
can you fucking believe this guy is
still doing it? Nobody Talks Hillary.
Nobody talks Bernie Sanders.
Huh? Is he related to the uh,
the chicken guy there? He's
Kinda got the same hair.
He's either that or the
fucking the oats guy. Right.
One of the other is those nice
too fucking hacky references.
Did you enjoy those now Jesus,
I got to go to the airport.
I have not even packed and I still
have eight more fucking minutes.
I got a needy pit bull
sitting in my fucking lap.
I have to some out eat and not
become a fat fuck today. You know,
I think I'm going to do, I'm going to
pack a lunch like a goddamn second grader.
I'm going to make a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich with some cheese and
crackers and like an apple, you know,
and as much as all these fucking weird
looking shredded 50 year olds that are
spray tanned out there,
you know those people and they've
gotten their first fucking a,
can you tuck the, uh,
the parachute under my Chin behind my
years they've had that fucking procedure,
you know, so they still have the a
heart monitor forehead, you know,
with the lines going across it. But
then like their fucking neck, you know,
they're looking like a WHO's who is
a classic fucking, just got a great,
AH, Jesus Christ. I don't know
any of the fucking act, you know,
class to the actor face. You know what
I mean? Judge shutting out confidently.
You know the jet black
fucking hair, right?
He used to dance in the fountain on
friends. You know, now you're on OJ.
My wife's been watching the shit out of
that thing. Huh? I can't get into it.
You know, I can't get too into it cause
I already know what happens. It's like,
yes, spoiler alert. He's,
he's found not guilty.
I watched the first one just cause I want
to see them dramatize whatever he was
doing in the back of the
Bronco. And I can't, I tell you,
as much as the tragedy happens,
whenever I see clips of that,
it always makes me think like, dude,
I would love a white full size bronco.
That's such a bad ass
vehicle. It's big, it's safe.
You know what's great about those,
those full sized Broncos
back in the day was the a,
I've talked about this before.
What do you call the, the,
the middle area between the front two
bucket bucket seats or captains chairs,
I believe they used to call them. Um,
what I loved about the console there in
the middle, when you open that thing up,
that was big enough that
if you insulated it,
you could throw ice in there and have
a 12 pack of Budweiser. You know,
they make it so hard to drink
and drive and enjoy yourself.
You know, nowadays, back in the day,
if you had a big truck like that, okay.
You know, your,
your biggest problem was how am I
gonna What Am I gonna pee into while I
continued driving down the street,
taking everybody's life into my hands.
You know, I shouldn't even say that.
A friend of mine got fucking hit by
a drunk driver and I ain't doing like
fucking 90. Her Damn car looked
like it was torn in half.
And I got to tell you the way they
make these fucking cars nowadays,
it's amazing. Oh, by the way.
So I found more information
on the 27 Lincoln Continental.
Evidently it's going to start at like,
like 45 grand or something like that.
They're trying to take out the Mercedes
Benz e-class and rather than going
performance and that they're trying to
go elegance. Like we're a little more,
you know, you ride on a cloud over
here as opposed to the, Whoa, Whoa,
I have a fucking Mercedes-Benz. I don't
know if that's the right way to go.
But, um, I also talked to the guy who, um,
who rebuilt my truck, um,
and I, I called him up.
I said, hey, this is the prototype,
the concept card has the suicide
doors. He goes, oh my God,
that looks fucking sick and all
that type of shit. And I go,
they're not making them that
way. He goes, I was like,
can you do if I buy this
car and I ship it to you,
can you fucking put suicide doors
in it? He goes, I got it. You know,
he had to look it up. He said, basically,
you're making the car a lot more unsafe.
You're weakening the overall frame.
When you take out that middle piece,
that's between the front and the second,
uh, in the back door, the B frame, fucking
post, whatever the fuck he called it.
Um, and I'm thinking like, you know
what, I haven't been in an accident.
You know, I drive like a fucking old
man. I can take out the middle fucking
the B beam post fucking thing,
whatever the fuck you call it. Right.
You know, I feel like it's like, you
know, when you have to get a permit,
like you can knock down a wall yourself
in your house and interior wall,
as long as it's not a load bearing wall.
I feel like that's what I would
be knocking out on my continental.
So then I would have like this,
the suicide doors, led lights,
that thing would look fucking sick.
And then I would like rear end a smart
car and I'd go through the fucking
windshield,
or I'd just go into a spin and I'd
be objected out. Those two food,
those two like cool
doors. So, um, I dunno,
you would think this day and
age if they, if they want it to,
is that way suicide doors went away
where they considered not safe.
I learned that doing the
Seinfeld comedians in cars
where I asked him two times,
like an idiot. I go, why can't they make
cars that look cool like this anymore?
And he basically answered saying,
because of the safety regulations are so
strict that they're basically basically
creating in such a small
space, all of them, um,
that they're all gonna
kind of look the same.
And then we saw another car and I said,
look at that thing. I was like, why?
Why can't they, why can't they make cars
like that anymore? And Jerry just went,
I already answered that question.
It felt like such a fucking dope.
Um, anyways, so, you know,
it's funny as I just talked to some
people on the radio in St Louis and uh,
I was telling them how,
how much I was not looking forward to
watching my team having to try to get a
point or two off of them that's coming
up Friday. And uh, they were like, well,
you know, who knows, maybe
when you come out here,
St Louis will be in the playoffs,
she can go to a game. And I was like,
that was the one happy hockey
thought I've had in the last,
I'm not going to lie to you like I was,
I've been so busy that I didn't even
notice like the first three games that we
lost. Um, and also like I wasn't,
I'm not one of those guys
that looks at the standings.
I just knew we were three seats. I'm
like, all right, so we're in, I'll watch,
you know,
as many games as I can towards the end
of the season and I'll enjoy us the first
round of the playoffs, I'm going to
be sitting there, right. My Budweiser,
my little shorty there, right. A
little fucking thing at Jamieson,
they have one of those up period. Right.
So by the end of it, I'm either like,
you know, happy that we won or I
just passed out drunk. You know,
if we start to lose the game,
then I do two to Budweisers and
two Jameson's in the third period.
Then you just,
you fall asleep and the next day you
wake up and you're so fucking hung over,
you don't give a shit that you lost.
You just trying to get yourself
physically back to where you need to be.
That's how I do it. That's the way an
alcoholic doesn't. I don't do that. Okay.
You fucking literal cuts. Why
would somebody do something
like that? So anyways,
I am going to be in
Wednesday, tomorrow night. Oh,
let me read the dates to wrap
up the podcast here. Well,
the first half of it before we then
listened to some Andrew [inaudible] mood
music and then we move into
some of the classic stuff, um,
from back in the day from
podcasting back in yesteryear.
All right, so I'm going to be
at the coliseum. It's seizes,
doesn't that sound impressive?
It's probably a 40 seat room. Um,
I'm going to be there. Uh,
tomorrow night, April 1st. Oh,
April falls, April 2nd.
I'm going to be at the Casino
Roma in Ramah, Ontario.
Wherever the fuck that is that I'm going
to be at TD placed stadium in Ottawa,
Ontario.
And then I'm doing the lol festival
in sub Sudbury Arena Ontario,
which is actually a, uh, it's
a minor league hockey arena.
The way they, you know, they set it up
so you can still do standup in it too.
I'm not like fucking center ice.
It's not get crazy here. Huh.
And then later on this month,
the 22nd 23rd and 24th of April,
I'm going to be doing a run St Louis,
Missouri, Kansas City, Missouri in Ames,
Iowa.
I have not been to Iowa since I did the
rich bitch tour with Charlie Murphy and
Darnell Rawlings way back in the day.
And I believe we did one of
the penguins comedy clubs.
And that's the last time I was there.
I am so excited to go to Iowa in April.
I've never,
the only time I've ever been to Iowa has
always been the dead of fucking winter.
And all the crops are cut down.
And it's like you're walking
on the surface of the moon.
It's overcast and all of that. And I told
you for the longest time, I was like,
how did slip not come from out
here? Like my idea, I should say,
of what Iowa was, you
know, just, you know,
beautiful pony tailed girls
running through fucking,
uh,
fucking stocks of corn. You know, if
their flannel shirts tied off going,
hey yo Galen, you know, I'm just
the girl next door does everything.
They got a southern accent, you
know, apple pies in the window.
Like that's what I pictured. And then
you get there and you're like, oh my God,
this is what Armageddon looks
like going to fucking Iowa in
the middle of January and
February. I'm telling you,
you've never seen anything like
all the crops are cut down.
The gray sky meets the baron
earth and you're like, I get it.
I get slipknot, I get math,
I understand madness. I get
this. This is fucking insane.
So I'm so excited to go there and
actually see it when it's lush.
And I watched like, wow, these people
feed the country. I want to see that.
All right. So anyways, looking
forward to that. Um, anyways,
so that is the podcast. Can I say
anyways one more fucking time?
That is the podcast. Uh,
thank you guys for listening.
Have a wonderful weekend. Yukons and
I will talk to you on Monday and um,
thank you to everybody that's going to
come out to the shows here in Canada.
Okay. All right. I'll see you
[inaudible]
who's at big going on on a Minnesota
with that weird last name that has like
three letter bs and an n in it or some
shit. I don't fucking know. Anyway,
let's plow ahead with the podcast.
This is the Monday morning
podcast for Monday,
March 1st a that aunties door and um,
yeah, I had a hell of a fucking
weekend out there in Houston, Texas.
I want to thank everybody who
came out to the Improv and um,
I had great shows Friday night that led
into Saturday night and Saturday night.
I think I might've had two of the best
shows I've had in recent memory. Um,
they would just, everything
sort of clicked. I kind of,
I was sitting in this
restaurant, um, eh, this is,
this is how clean living I am. Okay.
It's right before 7:00 AM I have been a
salad with fucking a chicken breast in
it. Right. I got my laptop. I'm typing
out this fucking script, finishing it up,
drinking a glass of water,
getting the shit out of the way.
And I just remember like
having this feeling like this,
this is what Tony Robbins does. You know,
that's how he has that fucking psycho.
Terminally happy fucking smile
on his face, you know? And um,
I don't know. I realized
some shit in that moment.
I brought it to stage and started riffing.
The whole fucking thing
worked and I recorded it.
But the beautiful thing about the
universe is when you hit something great
happens, something else
has to balance it out.
Like I get to see Peyton manning fuck
up the Superbowl and thus make me feel
vindicated. And then two weeks later,
a crushing fucking overtime loss.
It wasn't crushing cause they used,
they used to beat us by fucking,
these will be this like seven to one.
All right, you got to admit,
okay, you can hit a Fox.
Remember that back in the day it
was a joke. Our hockey was a joke.
First of all, 90% of the people in
the league were all from Canada.
Granted there were only six
fucking teams, but still, um,
and you guys used to crush us and now
we're breathing down your neck and you
better enjoy that gold medal.
Cause I got a feeling that's the last
one you're going to be fucking having for
awhile. How do you like that? Huh? Nah,
you wait till fucking next year buddy.
Now can you guys handle that
shit talk and all right. Anyways,
so twice this, I had incidents
with people in the crowd.
Um, and both of them were women. And uh,
I'm the first to tell you that I do have
fucking issues with women, but the, uh,
the first night, um, I was on stage
and there was this woman right down.
I don't know if it's stage left to
stage right from where I'm fucking at at
stage left. All right?
So I think that's the proper terminology.
Why the fuck do you guys need
to know stage left stage, right?
You're in the crowd. You
know, I go down to midas.
Do I need to know what fucking wrench
they're gonna use? I don't need, okay,
so stage left. All right, I'm looking
down and, uh, this fucking girl is, she's,
you know, she's talking,
continue on with my jokes.
It looked down and she still talking.
So finally I say, hey, it is sweet tits.
Why don't you, uh, what's the
problem? What are you talking about?
And then she does the
usual, hey ma, you know,
I wouldn't say she was attractive.
If she was in from a small town,
she'd be a Hottie, you know,
just out of percentages. But, um,
so she did the usual
like, what, what I have a,
I have no idea what the fuck I'm doing.
You know, 10 minutes later I look back,
she's still fucking talking.
It gets a little more heated.
I basically went to her table about six
times until I finally told her to shut
the fuck up and then I don't really even
fucking remember. Then all of a sudden,
next thing you know,
she's hammered and she's getting kicked
out when I got like five minutes left in
my show. So she threatened to sue the
place and all this type of shit. Now,
usually that's the end
of the night. You know,
the whole crowd is fucking clapping as
she's leaving because she's been fucking
annoying. Everybody around
them who paid to see the show.
All right, so a, usually
that's the end of it.
But you know what this psycho did.
She actually sent a letter to the
Improv and she tried to pretend that she
wasn't herself.
She tried to pretend that she was an
impartial member of the audience who
completely agreed with her and thought
that I was a fucking idiot. So, uh,
I want to read you a little bit
of this fucking letter here. Um,
to whom it may concern,
I attended bill burrs first show on Friday
the 26th and was utterly appalled by
his performance. I love comedy. Oh,
this is what you always have
to do whenever you bitch. Um,
and you're not there in person,
so they can't see what a
radiant human being you are.
You have to then after
you state your bitch,
you then have to fucking
show how easygoing you are
as a human being. So anyway,
she saw my show. She was utterly
appalled by it, by my performance,
and then she goes, I love comedy and I
certainly expect there to be rudeness,
crudity and what can be offensive topics.
That's what comedy is all about.
It makes it fun. That being said,
okay,
now she's established how fucking cool
and laid back she is back to trash and
old fucking heavy duty. Here
she goes. That being said,
Bill Bird took it way too far and he was
quite unprofessional to say the least.
While there was indeed quite
a lot to laugh at. Yeah,
that was the part where you were
sober, your fucking lightweight.
That was the beginning of the show
when you weren't fucking on your ninth
fucking drink and you actually paying
attention to the show. So yeah,
initially there was indeed quite a lot
to laugh at and I think this person is
trying to write as if it's medieval times
and I should be like fucking holding
this thing like a goddamn scroll.
I know that isn't mean evil ish,
but she's used, she's
doing that biblical thing.
What she's using extra fucking words
to try to sound intelligent. Well,
initially there was indeed quite
a lot to laugh at instead of me.
At first it was funny. Um,
anyways, the show ended up,
the show ended up being a complete
disappointment. Okay for it. Okay.
This is our complaint here for at
least 30 minutes. He, blasphemy,
God and the name of Jesus Christ.
He outright degraded the
Catholic religion. All right.
Now that's complete bullshit.
I only blessed to meet God,
the name of Jesus Christ and the Catholic
religion for about seven minutes.
30 minutes. What am I
fucking George Carlin.
I can't talk about
anything but 30 minutes.
Maybe you weren't so fucking
hammered. You dumb cunt. You know,
you'd have a better perception of,
of, of how much time had elapsed.
Oh Jesus. All right, let's
continue. Although I'll get this.
This isn't another thing.
Another thing was she's,
she's pulling this move again. He
outright degraded the Catholic religion,
although I do not belong to this
religion. So now you supposed to be like,
wow, she's not even part of that religion.
And even she found it offensive.
Have you guys picked up on that?
On Youtube at all? Like when
someone wants to trash Obama, um,
they'll say like a Bama is
the worst president ever.
And then they'll write and
I'm a Democrat, you know,
like you can prove it either way.
Just trying to cut people off the
past before they go, fuck you,
you Fox News watching right
wing, whatever, you know.
Yeah.
Women need to shut the fuck up. And
I'm a girl, that dumb shits. Okay.
So evidently she was, she was
offended and she's not even a,
she's not even Catholic anyway,
she said it was offensive and
what he said went on and on again,
while this type of thing
should be accept a expected,
he took it way too far and there was a
young lady who like I and my friends was
becoming offended. Yeah, of
course she was because she's you,
you fucking psycho. Can you believe
that? She thinks I'm this fucking stupid.
I don't know what this point is.
Probably not obvious to you guys,
but wait till I finish the
rest of this. All right.
I'm probably going to sound like some
maniac here, but I don't give a fuck.
I said,
there was a young lady who like I and my
friends was becoming offended and said
a few words instead a few
words to someone at our table,
you fucking lie and sack
a Twat. Anyways, a she,
he said when he rudely addressed
her, that's when I said a lady,
I guess lady is rude. Hey Lady,
could you do me a favor and look
at the show at some point? Um,
he said when he rudely addressed her,
she told him that she was Catholic.
That never happened. He had no
apologies or considerations.
Just utter disrespect. Okay.
First of all, she never said that.
She never said she was Catholic
and if she did, she said,
it's so quietly that I couldn't hear it.
So how the fuck could this random fucking
woman in the crowd here what she said,
Oh fucking thing. It's going to make me
mad again. All right, let's continue.
After he finally got off that
subject, his show just got worse.
This is when she's on
about her six strength.
It appeared to my friends and I that he
may have been getting heat from some of
the audience and that
he felt uncomfortable.
This may very well be the reason
why he continued to pick on the lady
[inaudible] this is why I'm
picking on her, not because she,
I as I'm doing my act, by the way,
I keep looking down and she's getting
some sort of Martini thing that looks like
there's a beer in it. I don't
know what the fuck it was.
It's one of those chick
fucking drinks, you know?
Like what if we take root beer and
second fucking roofie in it, you know,
she was drinking those
things. Okay. And uh,
so now she goes in this
very Mel, uh, he goes,
this may very well be the reason why he
continued to pick on that lady even at
one point telling her to
shut the fuck up. Yeah.
I told you to shut the fuck up because
you were talking the entire time.
You twat anyways. Ah, this
is downright unprofessional.
Who said that someone can not say a
few words to people at their table.
Did you see how obvious this is that
this is this the actual fucking woman who
would give a fuck this much that
you would write three pages.
They were quietly speaking and not
making any noise whatsoever. Oh,
yet you heard her say that she was
Catholic on the other side of the stage.
There was another table talking quite a
bit more and they were louder due to the
drinks yet he did not pick on
them. Do you want a fucking,
all right, let me just fucking relax
here. This is even funny anymore.
Like I totally lost. I've, I've
lost the whole humor in this.
This is fucking making me so mad. They
were more disruptive than anything,
although he of course made
jokes about it. All right.
There was this table next to
me. They were also drinking,
but they were more doing that church thing
where I would say something funny and
then they was sorta like fucking repeating
it. So they were a little bit rowdy,
but they were acceptable.
This woman who was fucking out drinking
everyone at the other table had
basically essentially her fucking back
to me to the point that if I fucking
punched her in the back of the head,
I would have got two
minutes for boarding pat.
Possibly a fucking game misconduct.
Alright, there's something for you.
We'll Olympic hockey fucking people.
Anyways, let's, let's continue here.
Actually, that would be
roughing, wouldn't it?
Let's say I took the mic stand
and I turned it sideways.
I could have cross checked around the
fucking neck. All right, here we go.
Now we are convinced that his wrong
demeanor was due to his discomfort.
After realizing that he had offended
some of the audience in order to justify
himself and ease any tension
coming from the audience member.
He said something along the
lines, don't listen to me.
I'm just an idiot up here
speaking. Pray for me please.
That was obviously a demonstration
of his uneasiness. That's this is,
this is how drunk she was.
What I was doing was I was,
I was telling people in the crowd that
if they were religious that I respected
their religion. All right?
Okay.
I just ha, I just personally
don't buy into it. Okay.
So I'm only stopping right now to
say this because I know some of you,
you get so religious, you get
so into it that you can add,
you get so holy that you can
actually commit murder. You know,
God's usually as a tool
or you know, vengeance.
I think that was the line
I used. I said, okay,
you shouldn't be getting mad at me.
You should pray for me
to help me see the light.
And everyone got a huge fucking
laugh at it about it. Okay.
And this lady is basically us.
I can't wait to email her back.
I don't know. I, I've,
I've flip flopped a hundred times
in my head what I was gonna say.
Okay.
You know, I just can't wait to, uh,
I think I'm just gonna
write back something really
quickly. Okay. Like, Ruth,
you actually pretending to not be the
dumb drunk bitch in the crowd is one of
the funniest things I've ever
read. Something to that effect.
Basically let her know that I know that
it's her and I'll see you next year.
At the Improv, you're con. Um, anyways,
I am very supplies prize at your club.
This is where she tries to, um,
yeah.
This is where she tries to
get me banned from the club.
I'm very surprised that a,
your club hosted this comedian.
It was a true disappointment.
I am embarrassed as I was the one who
suggested the Improv when my friends and I
were planning to on seeing a comedy show.
I do hope that you will consider not
having this comedian back as he gives your
club a bad name. If this is a, this
had been my first time to the Improv,
I never would've returned. You might
consider hiring some local talent.
There are several good
comedians in the area.
We are good friends with one
of them. If you like his name,
I'll be happy to give it to
DPP a bit. Bit. All right.
As for the lady who we picked on,
she and her table were
unjustifiably asked to leave.
There was no grounds on having them
escorted from the show right in the middle
of it. That's how drunk she was.
She got escorted out 50 minutes
into my one hour set and she's like,
she was escorted out in the middle of it.
Do you understand how
drunk this woman was?
I talked for Geez about
Jesus for 30 minutes. No,
actually it was seven minutes.
I was escorted out in the middle. No,
you were actually escorted out 50
minutes into the show when you were on.
You're fucking six drunk.
You're drunk. Can't,
there were no grounds of on
having them escorted from uh,
from the show right in
the middle of it. Again,
they were not being disruptive
or at all this, this,
this impartial person just wants to keep
talking about how innocent this fucking
lady is that she never met. If it hadn't
been for bill burr picking on them,
no one would've even noticed him. Okay.
The kids you tell, this is just the,
the fucking drunk argument they had in
the crowd and in the car on the ride
home, the loud table.
And the other side though is the one
that took away attention from his show.
I do understand that it is private
property and then anyone could be asked to
leave at any time, but this was
wrong to do. This is a time to do it.
I personally believe that she should
receive an apology from the Improv,
but mostly from bill burr. That's
clearly not my call. Just the thought.
What a fucking, ah, I don't know.
Did I take too long reading that
fucking thing. There you go.
You want to be a standup comedian? That's
what the fuck you have to deal with.
She's actually like a total
fucking control freak.
And what happened that night was
she completely lost on all levels.
You know it's weird.
You become like a part time psychologist
as you're breaking down the crowd as a
comedian and she sat at the
power position at the table.
The table is at like a fucking,
we'll say like a 30 degree
angle coming in stage left.
This is going to get technical.
All right, you fucks. Don't don't,
don't leave me here. She, you know,
she didn't sit at like the the chair
furthest away. If you sit furthest away,
everybody you're at the table with
has the back of their head to you.
So then when you want to fucking
talk, it's, it's a difficult time.
What she did was not only did
she sit in the first chair,
she sat on the first chair
closest to me, so the,
so all she had to do is turn around. She
had the whole fucking tables attention.
And when she stood up,
when she went to leave,
her whole table stood up like a
bunch of fucking minions. You know,
like you remember that dude, he used to
carry the fucking umbrella for puffy.
That's how they all got
up. It was pathetic.
And people like that surround themselves
with fucking weak people like that
because any normal people, person,
you know, think about that.
All you guys listen to
right now, if you're,
if your buddy was being a drunk fucking
asshole and got booted from the club,
would you get up and leave immediately?
Stand up like the fucking general just
got up. I mean, I guess maybe you would.
Could you be, well, Kay's drunk.
Maybe he's going to go fucking walk
out in a p on a cop or something.
I guess maybe. I Dunno. Anyways,
you know, before I emailed her back,
what do you guys think I should write
back and come up with something clever
other than calling her a con like
I did. I think I'm just going,
I'm going to write back something to the
effect that I realized that it was her
and um, I don't know. I don't fucking
know. Was that just a big waste of time?
Should I not have been bothered
with all of that? You know,
I don't know then and I had another
incident with another fucking person.
I Dunno. I, I have issues with,
with a beautiful women. I really do.
This is actually a bit I want to
do on stage and I'll just, I'll,
maybe I'll do part of it for you
here at bay. The basic idea, I just,
I don't respect them on a certain level.
I feel like I had to do something
to achieve in life. All they had to do
was basically they were born beautiful.
This, it's really not an accomplishment.
I guess you go to the gym,
you stay beautiful past a certain
age. It is an accomplishment I guess,
but you know, I dunno for, in order to,
as a guy to get around beautiful women,
you have to accomplish all this shit in
life and all they have to do to get to
where the fuck you're at.
After accomplishing all this shit is
basically take a shower and feather their
hair back like Farrah Fawcett and
they're in the fucking VIP. You know?
I also don't like them because a, I don't
know. I don't know if they're smart.
They, if they're smart, they're
absolutely stunning though.
I have to admit that. But you know,
okay.
If they're, if they're dumb, that's
like, it's like you got a Lamborghini,
but you find out it has a four cylinder
in it. Or even worse, my fucking hybrid.
Did that make any fucking sense? You
know, they have that one default emotion.
Oh my God. And they give 58
different reads. You know,
if they see something cute like a
little puppy, they're like, oh my God.
You know, if you do something
sweet from, Oh my God,
okay,
you know, you do something that
they fucking hate. Oh my God,
fucking idiots. They got three
words floating around right
there. And then with VIP, you know,
[inaudible]
and somebody said, uh,
was actually saying like,
I was trying to figure out
why I was finding these
fucking women's so attractive
other than the obvious that
they were good looking women.
This guy actually said, hey, bill, uh,
beside the obvious hot women
vigorously scrubbing the floor,
I really set that up bad. He's saying,
this is why men find women curlers
attractive. I just blew that joke.
He said,
besides the obvious hot women
vigorously scrubbing the floor,
I have to, yeah,
you so deserved a huge laugh on that
and I just fucked you out of it.
I'm sorry about that.
Um, anyways, he says,
I have figured out why we
love watching this so much.
When they release that stone,
the way they let it slide out of their
hand is reminiscent of the way a skillful
woman releases your cock after
delivering a massive hand job.
First of all,
I hope you're a surfer cause that's the
only reason why to the massive hand job,
Bruh. I'm fucking massive hands job.
Or maybe you just have a fucking bit or
maybe I'll just, you have a fat cock.
I Dunno. So anyways, she goes, uh,
they don't drop it. Don't push it.
Just let it slide out naturally as I go
to sleep with my boxes around my ankles.
Oh, I forgot. That was
creepy. I know. I read it.
I was supposed to just read the beginning
joke cause I thought the joke was
fucking great. I forgot the
fucking picture in his, Ugh guys,
with those fucking insect
looking legs on guy's legs,
like insects with that fucking hair all
over skinny fucking legs were a mess.
Fucking mess. I'm like
praying mantis legs. Anyways,
I'm a long time ago. I talked about
unacceptable. This is when, you know,
the podcast sucks and I'm just plowing
from fucking topic to topic and there's
just no sort of a no segway
other than dead silence.
Um,
[inaudible]
did somebody do a Bob Dole impression?
[inaudible] just the worst.
Can I tap out at this fucking point
37 minutes in a bad wedding stories.
I'm, hey bill, I haven't listened
to your podcast since the beginning.
Decided it was about time I emailed
you and told you how much I enjoy it.
Thank you very much.
Uh, [inaudible]. Okay,
let's get to the, uh, let's
get to the marriage thing.
Um, okay. I got a marriage
story when I was 23.
I was dating a girl and she got pregnant.
Ah Dude. Okay. Uh, so we decided
to get married. Okay. Stupid.
Fucking move number two,
even though a month before this I
was thinking about dumping her ass.
Stupid mistake number three. Actually
that was the smart move. That was,
that was the three card Monte
right there. Don't knock her up.
Don't fucking marry you're white.
Knock her up. Marry her dumper ass.
You know which one had the
marble? You fucked up. All right,
so all the plans are made, our families
meet each other. Okay. Just cause I,
you know, had to do that stupid
three card, Monte joking,
a desperate attempt to try to be
remotely funny. At this point. You don't,
it was, I have a blue wind screen
this week. I'm going to blow that.
I'm going to, I'm going
to blame it on that one.
You know my fucking
dog ate the orange one,
so I'm going to blame it on the blue
wind screen. Anyway. So basically,
sky's 23 years old. He
knocks up this fucking girl.
He decides to get married
even though he did.
He thought about dumping our month before.
So anyway, so all the plans are made.
Um, families meet each other, invitations
are sent out, all that bullshit.
So three days before the wedding,
I'm watching some stupid movie where
this guy tells his other guy that his dad
told him before his wedding. It's
never too late to change your mind,
to which his friend says, but you're
not married. And I guess it is.
That's a laugh. So anyways, uh,
so taking this as a sign from God that
I just happened to be watching this
movie. I canceled a wedding. Great.
Fucking move. All right.
Which is suffice to say, brought
a shitstorm into my life.
The worst part is that I actually
felt so bad. I marry that check.
Three months later I'll,
dude, you were out.
You were fucking out. So
basically I was a pussy.
Yeah, yeah, but too, that's a hard thing.
You were dealing with a lot of shit
at 23 your parents were crying.
She was knocked up. Yeah. I
wouldn't say you were pussy.
You gave into peer pressure anyways,
we were married for seven years with
every year being worse than the year
before. So we're divorced.
So we're divorced now.
So I guess I should have gone
with my gut to wrap this up,
I got a little gripe with, with chicks.
My ex used to ask me when the marriage
was going down, if I could go back,
would I not meet her? Which
I would say, fuck yeah,
I would avoid you like the
plague. Which she would say, uh,
but w at which point she would say,
but you wouldn't have our two kids,
don't you love them? And then he
would say, yeah, but then I'd say,
but I would never have met you. So
I would have never had the kids.
So in that scenario, the
kids aren't even a thought.
This of course would lead to a
huge fight about my lack of caring,
a moral to the story. Don't use
logic when talking to chicks. Aright.
That's actually not the moral
to the story. What it is,
is you got to think how women think, you
know, which you know, if you're lucky,
at some point when you're 90, you'll know,
you'll understand 10% of what the
fuck is going on in that brain. Um,
basically when she's asking
you that, she was asking that,
I would guess one of two reasons.
One, she was insecure that, you know,
you knocked her up and then you married
her and you know that you were gonna
marry her. Then you broke it off and
then you fucking married her. Uh,
believe it or not, I'm sure that's not
how she dreamed of getting married.
She probably dreamed of
meeting her soulmate and they
were so hopelessly in love
that everyone in the crowd had tears in
their eyes for, they never found a love.
Soap is great as there.
She could have been thinking that and
she wanted you to reassure her or she
probably was just banging you, you know,
it didn't want to fucking marry you
and didn't think that you were the one
either.
And all of a sudden she got knocked up
and she's probably sitting there looking
at the Sadie your fucking head. One
mornings you're eating pancakes,
trying to find where in
the world she loves you.
You know, on what fucking level, you know,
just watching your temples going
in and out as you're chewing,
just fighting that fucking urge to
slam a toaster over your fucking head.
You know, just wondering how the hell
did I end up with this fucking guy?
Why did I say Yes to this guy?
Why did I let him fucking drop a
fucking load in me? What is wrong with,
and just trying to make the fact that
you had these two kids justice justice
enough. You know, that's what the
fuck was probably going on. But uh,
I dunno dude,
you didn't really talk about how much
of a nightmare the wedding was that that
was the meat of the story there. I
think you at the beginning and the end,
but what are you thinking is
she's coming down the aisle.
What is your family thinking?
You're knocked her up and then you
dumped her and yet now you're like,
oh fuck it all marry or anyways,
and you're only 23 they know
you don't want to do it.
Those weren't tears of
joy, my friend, you know,
what are you thinking is
you're up there, you know,
was your Cumberbun like wringing wet
with flop sweat as you was standing up?
I can't imagine that.
Ah,
has anybody ever just ran out the side
door? Cause I can definitely see like,
oh my God, I don't know what to
say. How do I get out of this shit?
And then just in a
panic when they started,
Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh, Eh,
you turned around looking,
where is she a what?
A fucked and I have some wedding music
underneath this would've would've been
hilarious stuff. I bet if I
fucking prepared, you know,
you're looking for the
bitch, where the fuck is you?
And then she comes around the corner
and you're trying to make yourself lover
and she comes around the corner and you
just see that fucking face and you see
those eyebrows and you know we're going
to be touching by the time she's 40 and
you just fucking run out the side door
in those cheap tuxedo bowling shoes.
Okay.
And you know what I mean? And you're
in such a fucking panic, you know,
there's no way that you're going to be
able to get your car keys out in time,
get them into the door, open the
door, lock the door, and get in there.
And it's like people are gonna be coming
out running out of the church like some
fucking Zombie movie is. You're
trying to get your car started.
I made the move there is you.
If you're, anybody does that,
don't go to your car.
You keep running. Okay?
Most people get married in the suburbs,
so headed head for a wooded area.
All right? Go Online. Learn how to turn
your fucking Cumberbun into a tent.
Hang out there for a couple of days.
Let Shit cool off. Grow a beard.
Come back to town, get some provisions
that point you'll be so fucking filthy.
You just another homeless guy
wearing a suit. You know what I mean?
Just let her forget all about you and
then maybe they'll think that you're
mentally ill and then, uh, you know,
one day you just show up on your mother's
front steps and she faints her dad
catches you and punches you in the face
cause he's a former marine. You know,
haven't we all seen this movie? I'm
trying to say, run out the fucking door.
Run out the fucking door if you're in
that situation, during that situation.
All right. Uh, Bill, longtime
listener, first time writer, uh,
got a wedding story to tell you. I'm
23 years old now. The 23 year old.
I've been to a, here's one for you. Don't
go to a wedding or get married at 23.
They all seem to have bad stories. Um,
I've been to a few weddings and let
me start by saying in this story,
it wasn't actually a wedding
I witnessed. It was a wicking,
a Wiccan hand fastening. Okay. Now though,
for those of you not familiar
with the Wiccan religion, uh,
I just want to state at this
point, neither am I. Um,
I can't remember if that's the one
that actually has all those uh,
pagan symbols that, you know,
the Catholic Church then said that
they were devil signs according to the,
uh, fucking Rosetta Stone or
whatever that fucking movie was.
I read the book too. What the fuck
is the name of that Davinci Code?
Whatever it was called,
a Wiccan hand fastening.
And I know that because my sister
didn't invite people to our wedding,
she invited them to her hand. Fascinating.
That's why he knew it was a Wiccan hand
fastening and not a wedding because she
said, I'd like to invite you to my
hand. Fascinating. Jesus Christ.
Um, he said, if you're 41, you still
don't know what a hand fastening is.
Congratulations. Thank you. Because
I didn't, so anyways, he goes,
I'm 17 at the time, my sister's 23 or 24,
we both still live with our parents
are boyfriend and unemployed,
alcoholic living off money. His
mom left him when she died. Ah,
there you go ladies. There you go.
You don't have to settle for less
when this guys like him out there. Um,
anyways, um, the fuck am I,
why didn't I make this tight, bigger?
Jesus. What a flop this podcast is.
So anyways, so this fucking alcoholic
was over for dinner one night.
He tapped his fork on a glass of few
times to get everyone's attention.
We were three feet from him
and immediately my stomach
knotted up because I knew
this moron was about to say something
stupid. You got gotta I got to meet you.
You guys are fucking funny writers,
man. Some really talented people.
Listen to this fucking podcast. You
guys write better than I do. Anyways,
basically he announced his engagement
to my sister in front of my mom and dad
pulled out two onyx rings and they put
them on each other's middle fingers.
You know, I went to the Onyx Strip
club and now Houston last night.
How funny is that? Anyways,
it was dead silent. And um,
the look of a repressed horror on
my mom's face was unmistakable.
It was so awkward.
So I just started clapping
going Yay, quietly,
because nobody else joined in.
Oh, that's great. Is that
your role in the family?
You're the person who always tries to
make it better. Uh, God bless Ya. Anyways,
it was just dead silence and my sister
and her boyfriend kissing each other like
everything was fine.
A few months later I found out they were
financing those rings and going into
payments on them. Every,
my sister's collecting child support and
neither of them have a job and they are
financing onyx hand fastening rings.
Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ.
I can't believe there's more to
this story. All right, here we go.
Fucking knee deep. I got to go the
rest of the way. All right. Anyway,
so I finally,
finally gets to their hand fastening day
and they're doing the ceremony right on
Newport beach. It's in the
middle of the day on a,
on Sunday in the summer,
they didn't have, oh,
they didn't reserve a piece of beach or
anything. They just showed up and go,
hey, let's have the wedding here. Um,
the family we had, oh fuck. I gotta
sit closer to the damn screen.
I can't read anymore. The family we have
near the beach mostly all showed up.
All the people who live near
the beach mostly showed all.
There were about 30 or
40 of us. None of us,
none of us are dressed in beach clothes.
Half of them are in suits and dresses.
There are no chairs.
There's not even an altar.
Everybody's just standing around hot and
they can't sit down because there's no
chairs and they don't. They
don't want to ruin their clothes.
My sister shows up in an
all black gown with a veil.
The boyfriend is wearing like a Tux
with his face painted like one of the
misfits, kind of like a
skeleton face. Jesus Christ.
It sounds like the episode
of the office. Anyways,
they don't do any
traditional wedding stuff.
They just go right up front of the crowd
with their Wiccan priest or whatever.
The wicked priest is basically
just a friend of theirs.
He reads a bunch of a bunch of stuff
from a book in some other language.
My sister and the boyfriend are
responding in some other language.
Nobody has any idea what's going on.
Then all of a sudden the boyfriend pulls
out this crazy looking knife with a
what? A hilt. I don't know what that
is. Uses it to cut my sister's Vale,
then pokes the end of it into
his finger until he's bleeding.
He sticks the knife into the sand and
wraps his bloody hand around my sister's
neck while they kiss the stone.
Hippy priest holds up his book and
said something loud in that different
language.
I assume it was he equivalent equivalent
of I now pronounce you husband and
wife. I'm sure being comedian.
You've heard the sound of 50
people gasping simultaneously.
Family members in suits and dresses
are just walking away. At this point.
A lifeguard saw with the boyfriend did
with the knife called the cop and the day
ended prematurely with him getting cuffed
and driven away in a police cruiser.
Jesus Christ. Anyways, thanks for the
podcast. I really enjoy Jesus Christ.
How about a fucking round of
applause for that story? All right.
I think I have to read up on
the Wiccan religion. You know,
one thing I did like about that,
I did like the fact that they just showed
up and just decided to have a wedding
and they avoided all
those other costs. Um,
cause I wanted to say halfway
through that like, you
know, they didn't have,
they didn't reserve that piece of the
beach or anything and I was thinking like,
well, you never had to back in
the day. You know what I mean?
You just fucking had a wedding. There was,
it wasn't like nine zillion fucking
dollars. It didn't matter where you were,
but I guess you have to do that now. Uh,
because there's nine zillion people and
uh, and bankers run the fucking world.
Hey, speaking of that, did you get,
somebody sent me an email the other day,
evidently Europe elected a president.
You hear that Europe elected a
president, not England, not France,
Europe,
the entire continent now has a fucking
president has one guy in charge of all of
them.
See that just like those three d
TVs that are only a few months away,
that new world daughter is going to be
available right down at the best common
sowed come and fucking soon. If you go
on to read about the, uh, the bailout,
uh, rolling stone has a
great article and, uh,
usually I try to stay away from their
politics because there's so brutally to
the left. It's fucking
ridiculous. Um, you know,
they never trashed Democrats or when
they do, it's so like light hand.
They just doing it just because
they trashed a republican so bad.
They're trying to show that they're fair
and balanced like those other fucking
maniacs. Um, Fox News actually has a
store now when you go through the airport,
which I think is hilarious, they sell
water and that type of shit. So I dunno.
It's going to be, what is gonna
be one fucking news channel.
This is going to be one president and
one fucking currency of money and you
better do what they say.
That's going to be the
end of it. My friends
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].